big new releases seem few and far
between these days but there's still
plenty to play especially if you've got
xbox game pass here are eight games to
check out if you're subscribed to
microsoft service
when i moved to haven springs i hadn't
seen my brother gabe in years life is
strange true colors the latest in the
choice driven episodic adventure series
from square enix is finally on game pass
you play as alex chen who moves to the
sleepy town of haven springs to start a
new life only to be beset with tragedy
when she gets there with the help of her
newfound friends steph and ryan she's
determined to figure out what's really
going on in haven springs helping her in
this quest is her power empathy alex can
sense and even manipulate the strong
feelings of others and in true colors
she uses it to help the townsfolk of
haven springs in many memorable and
beautiful ways from a woman struggling
with keeping a secret from her
granddaughter to an unlucky kid with an
overactive imagination just like
previous life is strange games true
colors offers a fantastic indie
soundtrack including the likes of
radiohead phoebe bridges and mxm tune
but beware if you're streaming the game
on something like youtube or twitch
because
well let's just say streamer mode really
takes the
mood out of the moment there's no music
stop
please
but don't let that discourage you life
is strange true colours is a truly
heartfelt and emotional roller coaster
and as all episodes come in one package
you'll probably find yourself playing
all five in rapid succession to get to
the bottom of the mystery that lies at
its heart
[Music]
amazing
half bug half snack
bug snacks is a delightfully bizarre
puzzle adventure game from the team
behind octodad deadliest catch
originally a timed playstation exclusive
the game is finally making its way to
other platforms and is creeping on to
xbox game pass you play as an
investigative journalist invited to the
mysterious snacktooth island by intrepid
explorer elizabeth megafig but when you
arrive you find she's gone missing under
suspicious circumstances even weirder
are the island's local fauna the
eponymous bug snacks half animal half
delicious snack it's up to you to scour
the land uncover all the species and
capture the creatures to solve the
mysteries of snacktooth island bug
snacks is as adorable as it is zany and
definitely one that will scratch the
gotta catch em all itch of pokemon fans
it does get
a little dark as you need to catch the
cutesy bug snacks and then um
feed them to the residents of snacktooth
isle but with a theme song this catchy
from cairo caro benito
who could say no
[Music]
young horses also recently launched a
free expansion for bug snacks owners
called the isle of big snacks where the
bug snacks are
well i'm sure you can guess
are you in the mood for a cozy single
player adventure game about an adorable
turnip who commits crimes well if that
very specific mood strikes you turnip
boy commits tax evasion is just the game
for you it launched on steam in 2021 to
thousands of very positive user reviews
and now this cute menace i mean
seriously look at that little face is
making their way to game pass you start
the game by being evicted from your home
for failing to pay your taxes burdened
with debt and under the thumb of maya
onion you head out into the world to pay
back what you owe along the way you
solve puzzles traverse dungeons defeat
enemies solve problems for others hunt
for treasure and of course rip up tax
documents to erase your paper trail see
not all is as it seems and there's a
corrupt government and of course some
capitalist pigs to take down the ending
of the game depends on just how good you
are at committing and getting away with
tax evasion so keep that in mind as you
play oh and did i mention there are hats
to collect and wear
very important
okay so far these selections have been
very wholesome
sort of so let's completely 180 that
with seven days to die this zombie title
is a true mix of gameplay genres part
first person shooter part tower defense
part rpg and part survival horror
developer the fun pimps launched seven
days to die back in 2013 via steam early
access and now it's making its way to
xbox game pass following a nuclear war
that destroyed much of the world and
left it overrun by zombies it's up to
you to explore and survive there's a lot
to get to grips with but don't be
discouraged there are years of fan wikis
and a dedicated community ready to guide
you through
the world is a scary place
what are you doing
want to solve crimes from the safety of
your living room try out chinatown
detective agency a point-and-click
adventure game with a twist you play as
amira dharma an ex-interpol cop who has
set up her own private detective agency
as a mirror you get to travel around the
futuristic neon infused world to meet
clients and solve their cases but it's
not as simple as just solving crimes
you've got to make sure your agency
remains in the black and budget for
things like expansions and hiring staff
when it comes to doing actual detective
work chinatown detective agency requires
you to do your own research so yes that
can mean firing up google to search for
answers or asking the in-game librarian
mei for help if a gritty noir detective
game sounds up your street then this is
the one for you
if you have game pass ultimate or ea
play then here's a couple that you
should definitely take a look at first
up is lost in random which is described
by publisher ea as a gothic fairy tale
inspired action adventure where every
citizen's fate is determined by the role
of a dice i can't really summarize it
more succinctly than that so there you
have it if you're interested in the
premise you might want to know that the
game was written by ryan north who you
might recognize as the author of the
unbeatable squirrel girl playing as a
girl named even and joined by her dice
pal dicey your quest is to save your
sister but the odds are stacked against
you in the kingdom of random a wicked
queen with a cursed black dice runs the
show the gameplay is a mix of card
collecting and tactical combat all set
in gorgeous and twisted board games
where the world definitely has a touch
of the tim burtons about it
another one for ea play and game pass
ultimate subscribers but dragon age 2
has finally made it to game pass i know
what you're going to say there's a lot
wrong with dragon age 2 yes it uses the
same environment way way way too many
times and yes it was clearly made in a
bit of a rush and lost a lot of the deep
rpg-ness of dragon age origins but is it
still a fun rump yes is it less clunky
and more action-packed than the first
game also yes if like me you're
twiddling your thumbs waiting for the
next dragon age instead of replaying
inquisition again look we've all been
there why not give dragon age 2 another
chance
okay secretly i'm not even sure when
this one got put on game pass and kurt's
not here to tell me no so we're going to
round off this episode by recommending
alan wake's american nightmare this
stand-alone spin-off to 2010's alan wake
follows our beleaguered best-selling
author as he comes up against his
biggest foe yet
himself or rather the purely evil
version of himself known as mr scratch
american nightmare definitely leans even
more into pulpy horror tropes than the
original did and even added a new arcade
mode essentially a horde mode where
players can battle for the top spot on
leaderboards after they face waves of
enemies since alan wake 2's development
has finally been confirmed by remedy now
really is the time to go back and play
his first couple of adventures and if
you've got the time definitely hit up
the awe expansion for control to get the
full story
so there you have it the best games to
play on xbox game pass this month be
sure to let me know your favorites in
the comments below and let me know how
you get on with what i've recommended
i'm on twitter at lucy james games and
i'll see you next time
[Music]
oh